hey guys and welcome back to he Layah Heilpern
Show powered by icon plus so a really quick news
announcement for you so while the largest banks
and companies in korea are accelerating the
adoption of icons did service icon is also
launching three d5 projects in q1 or 2021
so decentralized identifiers could take deep by
mainstream as it's secure easier for institutions
to on board so great news always coming out of
of icon desk so i also want to say thank you to
my sponsors block buy so i actually use them to
earn up to 8.6 interest on my usdc so uscc is a
stable coin which is pegged to the us dollar and
so i'm going to leave a link in the description
a link in the comments a link everywhere so
if you guys want to sign up for them you can
um you can actually get up to 250 at the moment
and depending on how much money you deposit with
them so i think that's great and before we bring
on my um very exciting guests i want to just give
a huge shout out to coinflip so they're doing some
incredible work across the states to push bitcoin
mass adoption um they now have 1 200 bitcoin
atms which is really cool across the state so
giving everybody access to bitcoin so i also have
a discount code for them you can get 10 off your
transactions i think that's great so i will leave
that um i'll leave that in the comments below so
i'm going to introduce a guest today um he
comes from the traditional world of finance
caused a little bit of a start online recently
um on crypto twitter he is a former goldman sachs
executive and now actually has 98 of his portfolio
um in crypto so that is insane it is the man
that's based in the cayman islands it is Raoul
Pal l how are you doing i'm great how are you
i'm good i'm good it's hard to get all that out
you know but i'm glad to bring you in how is it
in the cayman islands how are you doing it's
great it's actually freezing cold right now it
got down to about 24 degrees which for us is like
the depths of winter but hopefully it'll go back
24 degrees that that's bad that's amazing you're
talking like actual degrees like we do in the uk
yeah celsius so that's freezing for us
i'm wearing jeans today that's not normal
oh my god you're living the dream out there well
i'm back here in the uk and it is absolutely
freezing um so yeah i want to talk about
your journey into the cayman islands because
you're one of the biggest names in finance you
know from not west to goldman sachs to real vision
and it all started at plymouth university so
i want to go back and i want to understand
how you got to where you are today and what are
some of the biggest challenges that you faced and
how did you overcome them well the story is is i
took my um for english people don't know what this
means they're a levels that's the exam make it
about 18 years old i had discovered cars pubs and
girls so i failed all of my exams and i had to be
i had to go and retake them at a cramer in london
in notting hill i then cobbled together enough
a levels to get one university offer which was
plymouth yeah the only place i could get into
so i got i went to plymouth i came out with
a decent degree in economics and law from
plymouth and graduated in a recession and
i wanted to go either into financial marketing
my dad was from a marketing background and i was
quite interested in that um but finance you know
it had been the end of the 80s and it had been
kind of everybody driving porsches and it
was all very exciting so i thought that's
what i wanted to do so i spoke to a friend of
my dad's uh at his birthday party once and said
you know what should i do i'm thinking about
marketing or finance he said well it's really
easy to think about because you can go and work
for a company like mars fantastic marketing
and i will give you free mars bars or you can go
and work for a bank and get free money i was like
okay that's what i want to do problem was i went
to a bad university we're not great university
and a recession and there were no jobs so that
made me think okay how do i how do i get to where
i'm going and that started my journey of living
in the future where i stopped thinking okay that's
where i want to be how do i get there and actually
what i wanted to do was work for goldman sachs but
they were never gonna take me i already had a draw
full of 200 rejection letters from everybody and
so i had to figure out okay how is it going to do
it and i became a i managed to get on the graduate
training program for a company called dow jones
tellerate which is like bloomberg it was like
it was the number two in the marketplace
at the time and i managed to get in that
and then eventually talked my way into a trading
desk where i was doing equity derivative sales
and i was doing that for six months started
doing quite well at it as a salesman and then
my boss left and i was made head of the desk
wow that's convenient that's a big opportunity
and that's what kind of launched my career that's
insane i think like you kind of have the playoff
here between luck is in like good timing um
but then also preparation from yourself right
because like you said you got you had all these
rejection letters but you were still sort of like
no i'm gonna push through so between if you had
to weigh up luck versus preparation you know which
would you say was k more into play here actually
you know it was very difficult to get luck when
you graduated into a recession so so that was
that was more cunning than luck and then luck
played you know luck plays a huge part but it's
leveraging luck that plays the biggest part
so once you see the opportunity then
you can start to really leverage it
yeah i hear you but there's this idea right that
in life we've got to get a good stable job we've
got to work that nine to five and once you work
that nine to five then you're on the right path
you're doing the great thing um but slowly people
sort of waking up and saying this isn't quite
you know the case so what is your journey in
that respect because obviously you know you were
at goldman sachs now you're sort of off in the
cayman islands you know you've got real vision
and all this stuff so what's your opinion on that
my opinion is and it's probably changing over time
but having something really good on your cv having
been exposed to people who are a lot smarter
than you have a lot more knowledge than you is
invaluable because it gives you a credibility
statement so nothing up until me working for
goldman really mattered because nobody cares about
natwest as a uk bank yes we were doing some cool
stuff at the time we were the leaders in the uk
and in probably in europe at the time but then
i got poached to go to goldman and that was the
biggest opportunity of my life it's like can
you set up hedge fund sales here and that's
what i did i was kind of well known for it in the
industry but with goldman it was like well this
is easy i can call up anybody and say hey i'm from
goldman sachs setting up patreon sales can we talk
so it was very easy to do um and develop it from
doing that but that move to goldman meant that
everywhere i went i've been vetted so
everybody says like you did oh ex goldman sachs
yeah whatever reason it's actually really to do
with the quality of people you're surrounded with
it gives you a network and you know yes to be an
entrepreneur from scratch is a great thing too
but anywhere you can build a network and and get
knowledge um actually supercharges everything in
the end so it's a combination of the two be
the entrepreneur but also if you can get that
meaningful network from working at an amazing
firm so a lot of people will go to google now
you know i worked at goldman it was this
number one requested place to work by
mbas around the world so you know i would not have
ordinarily got in that i i got into it because i'd
proven myself beforehand but anybody else if
you work for an amazing tech firm let's say
um and then want to branch out people always say
oh he learned at google or stuff like that and
you've been vetted so that's that's the tip
if you can ever orchestrate that that's the
best of everything yeah i think i can i can
relate because i i worked for many different
news stations before i sort of jumped full-time
into crypto um and you know when you're working
for the smaller news stations and you're trying
to get people on as a guest they don't really
know your station they don't really care you know
especially like the little london ones and you
know when you're when i've done some work at the
bbc so when i say oh yeah i'm calling from the bbc
they're coming on there's no and then you can
also say oh well i used to work for the bbc
and now i'm doing that right credibility
statement and then okay here we are now
yeah exactly so speaking of here we are now you
are notorious for holding um the majority of your
portfolio in crypto so that's insane but before
we get into that i want to know why bitcoin and
when did you first come across it i'm talking i
wanna heal hear that red pill orange pill moment
so i was living in spain writing my kind of
institutional research product global macro
investor over the financial crisis and the
european crisis in 2012 when europe almost
fell apart when the banking
in spain where i was living
almost completely broke down and so i've been
watching all of this and we've been seeing
the growth of debt and a lot of structural
problems within the finance industry like who
owns what when lehman brothers lost so i realized
there was problems and then the solution starts
to become printing of money and so it got many of
us down the path of okay what does this all mean
and gold becomes one of those things at the time
i was more worried about the financial system
itself so i was going around with a bunch of
kind of well-known hedge fund people uh looking
at setting up the world's safest bank uh and we
this was going to be a non-fractional reserve
place of for people to store assets and have
services and it's hard to set up a bank so we
kind of gave up eventually and i had a round table
for global macro investor members in spain and i
was talking about some of these journeys that i
was on and a guy presented to us all on bitcoin
he's another ex-goldman sachs guy a guy called
the mill woods who's gone on to do a lot of
amazing things in the industry um and emil is
very below the radar screen so i probably hate
the fact that i mentioned his name and so um what
happened was he presented bitcoin as the answer
and i'd seen the rise from about 2011 and had
been following it a bit i started writing articles
about it and invested first time in it and maybe
2012. i think 2012 i first started investing in
bitcoin so i bought it 100 in a month and i sold
it i was like okay that was quite interesting
uh and then i kind of followed it for a bit
and started getting people more interested in
it and then i kind of reinvested again probably
in 2014 and sold out into the big rally in 2017
as i got confused about forks and you know what
does this all mean i don't really know so i'm
gonna get out um and so so that was that i then
started to learn about blockchain technology again
from emil and a few of the others at the round
table coming out of that round table is why people
like dan tapierra and mark yusko are all because
they're all global macro investor guys that's why
they all got into bitcoin it's because they all
heard about at the same time we're all like okay
then we started hearing about blockchain
technology that got us all start thinking about
the digital asset space overall and where this is
all going again this was super early kind of 2015
we started learning about that whole space um
and so from that i then got back in again because
i'd sold out i wasn't back in again the price had
been falling and then dan tapiero started annoying
me almost every day by saying we need to talk
about bitcoin i'm like i'm not interested right
now there's a lot going on with a dollar a lot
going on with bonds he goes no we need to talk
about this and so eventually we did a piece on
real vision and um and then dan got me back into
bitcoin again which was 2018 and i started
investing again and spending a lot of time in the
space so speaking of dan and bitcoin and stuff i
watched a video um on i think i think it was real
vision at the beginning of this year um before
well actually not before actually in march as soon
as everything just kicked off right you mentioned
printing of money everything shut down so i want
to talk about quantitative easing because i find
that it's such a such a like a controversial
kind of topic you know people you know central
bank sort of do it to stimulate the economy and
everything's all very exciting and you know joe
biden's proposing another 7 trillion it's all
very great but you know people like in this space
people like you you know we're all quite concerned
about this we don't necessarily think it's
great so talk to me about quantitative easing um
especially how you know what we what's what we saw
happen in march and how the year has kind of like
looked since then yeah quantitative easing means
different things to different people in terms of
in terms of its effects yeah everybody in the
stock market thinks quantitative easing is what
drives the stock market higher the central
bankers thinks it's what stimulates the economy
the europeans probably thinks it's what holds
together their economy because if not all the
banks go bankrupt and the crypto space in the gold
space thinks it debases currencies right so we've
all got a different narrative based around this
the narrative that i've found is most consistent
is the debasing of fiat currency over time and i
started looking at this in a different way i came
at it with gold so i thought okay if gold is money
let's take that as a hypothesis then gold should
establish a price versus other things over time so
i chart gold versus real estate gold versus equity
markets gold versus copper gold versus things
right real assets and you can go back 100 years
200 years and most of the time it trades here in
the range so it's consistent in saying it prices
money you know the value of goods and they they
vary around that so then i started putting gold
versus a basket of 27 global currencies because i
saw everybody's printing so let's see not gold in
dollar terms but against this basket and lo and
behold the picture comes clear that as they print
gold rises versus these currencies they stop
printing it flattens out they start printing
it rises i'm like huh fascinating so it's showing
you that even though the printing of money doesn't
necessarily generate inflation i the cost of
your tvs you know in the supermarket don't
go up but the value of your money falls in this
kind of weird world of foreign exchange markets
and if they're all doing it you don't see it
because it's not like your currency's falling
it's not venezuela what you're finding is all
of them are lowering in value versus hard assets
which is one of the reasons the art market's
gone up and the collector's cars market's gone up
and gold's gone up and bitcoin's gone up so it's
that whole concept of easing so then when we saw
this happen in march we realized that with this
much debt and this bigger economic shock it was
going to be massive and it was going to be quick
as well because it's the only trick the central
bankers knew because interest rates were zero so
then they also explained that because velocity of
money is low because most of the banking systems
around the world aren't operating properly
the only way to get money in people's
hands was give it to them directly
but the governments couldn't afford to do that
so the central bank were essentially going to
pay for it by the back door and once you started
doing the joining the dots and looking forward
i realized okay this was going to be a
really unique moment in time for bitcoin
because it was going to be a key driver i'd
also followed previous recessions and the
quantitative easing or the stimulus tends to go on
18 months two years maybe three years afterwards
so this was only the start um and so that's why
i got very aggressive very quickly in the space
so what does that mean for the dollar then right
because the dollar is supposed to be um you know
this global currency people sort of run to the
dollar you know even i know i know venezuelans
are obviously buying crypto but they're also
buying the dollar um you know all over um these
kind of countries you have kiosks where people can
literally change their money into dollars so what
do you think about the dollar i mean it's down do
you think people say you know it could potentially
become the end of its lifespan do you think it's
still um i guess you know i mean i know sort of
talk about gold is that safe haven asset but the
dollar do you think that has much of a lifespan
do you think it could be replaced uh no i don't
think it's gonna replace fully um right now eighty
percent of the world's transactions are done in
dollars while the us is 25 percent of world gdp
so it's actually it has an outsized impact
on the globe that's one of the reasons all
of these other central banks are trying to move
to central bank digital currencies and talk about
trying to reduce the dollar's weight in the world
that will happen will it happen yet is the dot
has the dollar rolled over properly yet or is
this the bottom end of a range i'm not entirely
convinced that it's rolled over yet i still think
the dollar may go higher i could be wrong i've
been wrong this year on it um if it continues to
go lower well we've got this narrative of what the
imf and the bank of international settlements and
everybody else is talking about which is either
fragmenting into basket currencies using central
bank digital currencies or doing something that
reduces the dollar's weight in world trade which
everybody desperately needs if that's the case
then the number of dollars held by people
will fall and the dollar will fall itself
so again there's there's a whole other narrative
in the background that is very very positive
for crypto i do not think the dollar is at risk
of hyperinflation uh loss of reserve status or
any of that that's just narratives of people
wishing that their assets assets go up faster
it's not the way the world works yeah i think
it's pretty interesting um you know especially
in the crypto space there's this huge narrative
of um you know inflation and we're not seeing
hyperinflation it's not it's not what we're seeing
um no and we're very very very unlikely to see it
because of this aging demographic this massive
population the fact that the banking system
doesn't work fully to create hyperinflation
is actually really really difficult to do
so you know it's not even clear we can generate
inflation don't forget the japanese have been
printing money for 20 odd years now they have been
fiscally stimulating for 30 years they're buying
their own stock market they're doing everything
and they still don't generate inflation because of
demographics and demographics is the key driver of
everything so no i don't believe in any of those
narratives could that happen in 30 years time 40
years time maybe still doubt it okay that's pretty
yeah i think it's pretty interesting but you know
when we look at um these safe haven assets there's
this huge um you know tug of war between gold and
bitcoin um especially um you know i guess in your
community as well i mean i know you mentioned
dan tepiero there so what are your thoughts do
you think you know they could work simultaneously
as the safe haven assets gold and bitcoin could
bitcoin potentially you know surpass gold i mean i
know mark josco has sort of made comments on that
it could if it reaches a certain market cap um
they exist together they do similar things one
is for the modern age which is bitcoin actually
integrates perfectly with the new digital system
um and so it makes much more sense it also is
generational sure gold's been around for five
thousand years is not going away it will always
be a store of value but you know if you're younger
you probably have a propensity to understand the
value of a digital asset better than um somebody
who wasn't brought up with digital assets so i
think there's a generational shift so i do think
over time because bitcoin is not only this kind of
reserve asset store of value pristine collateral
which is what gold is it also as a technology and
it has that whole technology layer that offers
a different potential future so i think over time
the combination of those the knockout punch which
means it outperforms over time which is one of
the reasons i sold all my gold i've seen you know
bitcoin is basically outperforming every other
asset on earth and we haven't even started the
peak point of the halving cycle pattern so you
know the chances the point of owning any other
asset right now is is almost zero um so gold will
probably underperform but gold probably goes up
too so what is it about bitcoin though because so
how much of your portfolio is actually in bitcoin
i i mean i read recently that it was 98 but i
don't know if that's just like crypto in general
yeah no 98 is crypto in general of which it's
an 80 80 20 split between bitcoin and ethereum
good choices good choices so why bitcoin what
are like the top five things you have to do i'm
not gonna tell anybody anything that they don't
know although i think i was the guy who came up
with the pristine collateral idea is what i
like about it is obviously the res the the
restricted supply there's nothing like
it you know the distributed nature of it
um the divisibility exchangeability um you know
the digital asset the way it can be moved around
the world is is phenomenally powerful um and the
immutability of the whole thing and the blockchain
technology so all of that is great everyone knows
that at application level i think it's it's very
interesting just as a replacement to gold you know
it works you can store it offline much you can do
with gold and a gold vault but it's it's easier to
transport and there's a number of other benefits
i think um so the store of value thing is pretty
obvious the collateral thing is a very different
thing that people haven't got their heads around
so the world runs on collateral so collateral is
what allows you to borrow money the whole world
runs on one true source of collateral which is
us government bonds european government japanese
government bonds they also are but u.s government
bonds are the the most prestigious collateral of
all problem is is that collateral they can issue
more of it at any one stage and in a recession
when the value of the collateral so if you want to
borrow money for me it's a bad recession you can't
get money and you want some of this collateral so
you can borrow money you should pay me more money
for it the current system is the opposite because
the central bank lowers interest rates and the
price and collateral actually gets cheaper so
i'm taking risk and lending it to you but i'm
not getting paid the reward bitcoin changes that
dynamic because i'd be able to charge a different
rate for lending you my pristine collateral
because you can't mess around with it it's
distributed there can be no more supply
it's got recorded ownership there's a whole bunch
of things that doesn't happen with the treasury
bond market so you know i i think that's one
of the key things for me that i think okay
i can see something massive that this could be
the base layer of an entire financial system
so then with all of that in mind where do you say
the base layer of an entire financial system like
that's a huge statement you know because there are
people out there whenever i post about bitcoin i
mean you know people were screaming scam this
that and you know all these things and obviously
to say these kind of things they obviously don't
understand it but you know it's difficult well
it's not necessarily difficult to use but grandma
can't use it yet you know that's sort of like what
we say this is why it's priced as its price right
this is why it comes up like metcalfe's law which
is the adoption effect right so it's still being
adopted so we've got to that yet you know my job
as a macro guys to live in the future as i talked
about before so we're looking at possible futures
and that seems like a pretty high probability
future potential and it's the path of getting here
to there is where you make all the money it's not
there because when it's there it's a low volatile
risk-free asset i want to take it when it's
risky and nobody believes it because that's
when you make all the money when everybody adopts
it that brings all the money into the space yeah
i'm totally with you but i'm okay so you're living
in the future tell me how do you see this asset
though do you see it as a store of value do you
see it replacing the dollar i know you said not
quite do you see it as a global currency do you
see it's a global reserve currency like what is
bitcoin's place what could its place be that's bit
we don't know could it be the pristine collateral
that the world uses to offer leverage on yes
that's certainly quite possible is it likely to
be the payments layer don't know but could it be
you know we're seeing bitcoin wrapped on ethereum
there's no reason it has to be the platform it can
be the asset so will we see other central banks
or central banks put it onto their balance sheets
for sure because if it goes up a lot and it's hard
money and you're a latin american country that's
had problems with devaluations and all of this
well game theory would suggest that
somebody's going to try it soon
and it's going to make their currency go
up and it's going to help them and in which
case it encourages others to do it so i do
see adoption by central banks um i do see
a dual world where fiat currency and bitcoin
exist and one is an on-ramp and off-ramp so you
happen to live in a country and you live in that
country you have to pay your taxes in that country
but you want to store your money in the
universal currency i think that's pretty true too
so could bitcoin be everything there's definitely
a probability of that how high that probability is
i don't know because we're looking 20 or 30
years out at that point so it's too difficult
to assess but i do know we're going to move
towards that and again in investment terms
that moving towards it the rate of change is rule
where all the part where it gets very interesting
so you got yourself into a bit of um stir online
i'm talking regulation talking xrp we'll get to
xrp in a bit um but with regards to regulations
so you said that um regulation will come and you
will still use the crypto essentially um which
is pretty interesting because actually today i
read a news article that um france have now um
brought in a potential new kind of regulation
which would actually stop french people
from using any anonymous crypto accounts so
given the nature of crypto that's that's quite
huge um for regulation so how do you see do you
see regulation as this necessary evil in terms
of mass adoption or do you are you do you support
regulation what are your thoughts the world is
always about trade-offs and something like bitcoin
doesn't care what you think it should be it will
be what it is right it's a distributed system that
has a life of its own so it will go wherever it
goes depending on the demand and use cases so if
people want it to go up in price then more people
need to buy it it's the very nature of the asset
if more people need to buy it then the reality
is it won't be driven by retail investors
it'll have to be driven by institutions those
institutions cannot buy it without more regulation
or enough regulation so if not their trustees
won't allow them to buy it and it's dead so in
which case it remains is what it is dead as a as a
institutional asset so in which case it's a retail
asset that's okay too it's just a different
future but if you want to have a hyper bitcoin
coinalized world the traditional financial system
has to use it and that's going to take regulation
i am prepared to take the trade-off
of privacy because i don't think we
have any you know we're currently on a google
chrome browser they know exactly where you are
that you're talking to me where i am they know
my email address they know everything about it
they know what websites i've just visited they
know every single aspect they know you know
we are tracked by everything and everybody
so i'm not that fast and blockchain
tracks all of the movements of the money anyway
so my anonymity if it's to avoid paying taxes
well you can play that game and maybe you get
caught maybe you don't that's up to you but i also
know if i live in a country where taxes are due
for services i'm happy to pay them other people
aren't i get that um but unfortunately that's why
you've got a passport that's what it tells you is
we will protect you we will give you services
you may not think you get the value for money
but if you want to live here you have to pay taxes
that's what it is what people want it to be is a
different matter so i don't see a problem with it
i don't see a problem with regulation i've worked
in financial services my whole life uh regulation
is just part of what it is i also know that this
is an incredibly smart community of developers and
if they try and stop some form of custody wallets
that can't be uh anonymous somebody will
figure another way out because nature
it's almost impossible to fight that battle so
what we will find is the main players in the space
will be regulated both the investors and the
service providers and a ton of smaller service
providers that offer different solutions that
will be not regulated because they will find
jurisdictional ability or other ways of doing it
so i don't worry about it whatsoever i think the
market might even sell off on it because there's a
panic and i think that's going to be a huge buying
opportunity because two things happen one adoption
is good secondly people will solve the problem for
individuals who who want anonymity yeah but i
i think what kind of gets me is that you know
solving the problem of anonymity i think that that
anonymity given the news about france is going to
be taken away i just don't think we can have that
kind of anonymity you don't have any anonymity now
you have a bank account you have a credit
card the amount of cash transactions is
limited in europe you're only going to
take out a certain amount of cash um
so there is i mean anybody who thinks there's
this free world of money is it's nonsense
nobody can but that's the goal though isn't
it but that's the goal and so don't find what
right the goal of bitcoin there is no goal
it's distributed it goes wherever it goes it's
a network it's not a person it's not a philosophy
it's none of those things and everyone hates that
but i said look you can have your own view
on it and if you can corral enough people
to do the same thing as you but bitcoin is not
that it's a living breathing network yeah it's
pretty interesting isn't it because the community
is so tight right and there's narratives and
there's ideas and the propaganda is wild like it's
like state-of-the-art propaganda like and so i
think like i think it's really interesting to hear
somebody actually say well actually you know who
says that's the goal we don't even know the person
that created it so how do we and they're not in
charge of it nobody's in charge of it so that's
all narrative so why does these narratives exist
because different people want different
things for themselves and their future
you know there's a lot of people are angry with
how things are but also there's something about
bitcoin that most people don't understand
why did facebook get so big it's because it used
behavioral economics which is the like button
daniel kahneman taught all of these guys from from
um google facebook twitter in fact every major
platform was taught by the guy who won the nobel
prize for behavioural economics they explained
how the dopamine system works and how like buttons
and follows and likes make us feel rewarded right
you can affect human behavior then that was in
2007 that he basically held this famous summit
for all of the leaders of silicon valley who
adopted it on mass and took over the world then
in 2009 comes bitcoin bitcoin is the perfect
behavioral network because it rewards you in money
the more people you bring into the network the
more your money goes up that by definition will
create tribalism because everybody is now
incentivized for their network to go up
more than the other network and for all other
networks to fail it is an incredibly powerful
tool for building a network where you have money
attached to it so imagine if every facebook like
was a dollar imagine what that would do or
everybody you brought onto facebook page
and facebook shares that's what bitcoin is
it's incredibly powerful and that's why it
creates narratives because like a religion it's
all about getting more and more people into it
yeah i mean you touched on two things
there so the tribalism is something i
really want to talk to you about but i want
to go back a sec i can't remember what the
netflix documentary was i watched the netflix
one about maybe you know the social media
um uh social network yeah whatever it was yeah
yeah and wow that blew my mind i mean i knew
already the programming and this but you know it's
the dopamine it's the like pulling down and seeing
the refresh getting the hit the notification
if you haven't seen it watch the secrets of
silicon valley a two-part series on the bbc that
was five years before the netflix documentary
and it is unbelievable and explains this in great
detail everything that that is going on here
yeah and like on this documentary they even
have to have um i think there's a job now about
digital ethics you know if it's ethically okay
to because they know that they're programming
us they know that they're doing that um you
know every time every time they get follow
every time they get a notification it's a
dopamine hit so they know that they're sort
of creating that addiction so they now have
people in you know actually job vacancies for
you know people understanding whether this is
ethical or not well this is a real problem because
once you've unleashed the genie out of the
bottle of behavioral economics and big data
everybody figures out how to
use it for different means
and it splinters everybody into different groups
um and it it's almost impossible to deal with
because it's a network right so it's not centrally
pushed facebook's not centrally pushed yes there's
an algorithm and stuff like that but it's a
network that everybody's incentivized to get
more people into the network because it makes them
feel good by getting the dopamine hit of the likes
it's crazy and that's where we are and bitcoin
is the like the most perfect echelon of this
of anything i've ever seen and most people don't
really understand that so you mentioned tribalism
so this is hot right because you were attacked
for wanting to know a little bit about xrp
um so what did you learn about xrp um not a lot
i mean i just had one interview but you know what
was interesting as i said i've got an open mind
to it when somebody whenever in the investing
world when everybody says they hate something it's
usually the time to buy it i haven't bought xrp
maybe i never will but i reached out to somebody
i really trusted santiago velez and said look tell
me about it and he's a super super intelligent
very rational very balanced person and he sat down
with me for just over an hour to explain how much
of a use case it has and how it's being used and
where it could go and again he's not saying it's
definitely going there he's not part of the xrp
army he's just saying listen rel the narrative is
behind the reality um and then that is it's a scam
because a centralized company issued the tokens
he's like yeah that's pretty normal most companies
issue shares so yes it's with the token it's
the defined amount we know how many it is
and this is how it works and then this
is who's using it and this is its value
system and this is how it could appreciate
in value and i'm like okay i get it this is
you know i know there's still people who say he
doesn't understand it's a scam it's not it's just
a different thing and it's not bitcoin nor is
ethereum bitcoin nor is anything else bitcoin
bitcoin is bitcoin and so we don't need to
compare them it's like comparing saying well
it's not an orange no it's an apple no it's not an
orange i can't hear it's not an orange no it's an
apple it's different fruit that's what's going on
right now yeah i i think it's pretty interesting
i think it's kind of um quite interesting because
the bitcoin community is all about you know
generally speaking freedom um which kind of
implies freedom of everything right like freedom
of speech freedom of thought freedom to you
know understand more especially when we look at
bitcoin as views on politics and everything
that's been going on at the moment whether it be
you know counselling people and so on there
seems to be some kind of common ground that
bitcoin has sort of had when it comes to
this thing um which is why i'm surprised
that we're not allowed to ask questions like
wait what is xrp you know what what is ethereum
or could there be a future financial system
where there are many protocols there's an
interoperability layer across them that allows
assets to move you can have bitcoin that trades on
xrp's network and on ethereum's network can that
happen yes will it happen yes will somebody it's
already happening it's already happening so get
used to it but to say it can there can only be one
you might say i think there's only going to be one
in the future so i i want to bet on that i'm fact
i'm so passionate about it i'm going to short the
other ones that's how the world actually works by
saying you can't even talk about xrp because
you're an idiot for not seeing what we see is
religion and i don't think that's right but again
if you remember its behavioral incentive structure
is if you can get your network to be the one you
make all the money then your bags pump basically
yeah because you take over the world so therefore
you're incentivized not to play across networks
but once you start looking at the rest
of the world and understanding okay
this is a whole future financial system that's
all going to net together in this incredible new
way then you're incentivized to say well other
things may be undervalued versus bitcoin some
may be overvalued and that's how we can invest
accordingly to take advantage of the whole space
and again somebody may say oh it's all going to be
built on bitcoin great then just invest in bitcoin
if you think they're all a scam that's i've been
saying to people a lot of people say well ripples
are scams xrp's the scams are fantastic
short it that's how markets deal with that
you short it and you can make money but then yeah
i mean no you know i wouldn't do that oh you can't
short a scam on that really yeah i mean i you know
like i said that's how financial markets work that
that's the that's the free market for you you
like it you don't like it do your research you're
incentivized to do your research um so you know
no one's forcing you to buy xrp i want to get your
thoughts actually on privacy coins have you looked
into them much um i mean i know i was yeah go on
tell me about your thoughts on privacy points um
there will be a place for them and you know some
will get regulated and some will be used you
know i think there's a place for all of this
you know privacy coins matter particularly when
people are they really matter when you're in a
jurisdiction that is oppressive in terms of comes
with violence adherence with violence well then
having privacy in the extreme is incredibly valid
and i think it will stay around for that you know
will the us try and shut down this kind of stuff
of course they will um and we've seen this before
i've talked about this a couple of times um in
the uk back in 2014 something like that no earlier
the whole bunch of synthetic drugs that came
onto the market and they were called plant
food at the time okay i don't recall right
it's a synthetic stimulant right it's a coke
interesting kind of thing yeah it came out and
obviously they weren't banned so everyone was
importing them from china it was a fraction of
the cost of drugs and it went viral in the uk
and what was that but what was it what was it
what was the substance it was a synthetic thing
that triggered the same sensor sensory system oh
and it made it and so this went viral all across
the world now so what the regulators did was they
tried to ban it by saying this chemical formula
substance is banned so then the chinese reinvented
another one and then another one and another one
and the regulators had to then figure some
all-encompassing way but they couldn't get
rid of it new zealand in the end just said
fine it's illegal we can't regulate it um
see different jurisdictions deal with stuff like
this internet privacy is the same issue ins you
know there's many issues on the internet the same
china you don't get the choice the us you get
probably more choice than than you need to have
different countries will and europe will change
will probably be somewhere in the
middle um and it's just how it is
yeah i was talking to um a couple of people
from the monero core development team and
they gave quite an interesting opinion they
were sort of like well you know we have cash
cash is inherently anonymous um to obviously
some extent um and the same aml procedures
that are put in place for cash will be put in
place for privacy points to say you want to go
and buy a house with um a load of monero the
the person you're buying it from might have
several regulatory you know um and compliance
things whereby you have to sort of give proof
of funds and say yeah you know and they'll say
like they do with cash so in europe right now
most countries somewhere averaging about 5 000
euros you're allowed to use for a transaction
so you regulate that and say fine if you want
your your cash money no problem with that
anything over 5000 euros has to be declared
for aml and that's it and that will happen
now if you don't want to bring in if you don't
want to bring it into your system i into your tax
system same with cash nobody has to know about it
so all of spain still operates with cash you know
stuffed under their mattresses and in bangkok but
if you want to bring into the system it's bloody
hard unless you'll find somebody else who'll
accept cash so things trade at different prices
yeah absolutely and i kind of see that being
the situation with cryptos right because i think
that's the hardest thing you can trade anonymously
even with bitcoin um but as soon as you get to um
the the on-ramps and the off-ramps that's why
you hit the kyc and other than that there's no
way really to bring into the system unless like
you said you know you're dealing you know i guess
peer-to-peer literally if you could offer me a
service in bitcoin yes and the problem is is i'm
not sure whether you can get away with selling a
house for no transaction so it's it's difficult
it's difficult so yeah i can give you bitcoin and
nobody knows about it but what can you do with it
what can i get an exchange it's actually it's it's
tricky yeah it is so just finally where do you see
the space then in 20 years from now i know it's
impossible to kind of see but and the financial
system in general where do you see it all i i
think we're headed towards the internet of money
by a very broad definition which is digital assets
have value and digital assets are transferable
exchangeable recordable all of those things
and many most physical assets will be digitized
in terms of its value capture and transfer of
value whether it's the art market or or you know
thing the trusted ownership of everything will
be on blockchain technologies which ones who
knows um but that's definitely coming you know the
tokenization of all assets and income streams and
revenue streams and intellectual property rights
and everything is coming and it it's all coming
um so you know it change it it's gonna change our
world as much as the internet changed our world
yeah i totally think so and actually i do have one
last question for you um because you mentioned it
earlier cbdc's what do you think is going to go on
there because i have this kind of idea in my head
um just maybe i've watched too many films
i don't know but i have this idea whereby
i feel like we're gonna have a kind of like tug
of war between because like you said everything
is inevitable it's gonna go digital i always
say this everything is digital from you know
dating shopping whatever it is it's all digital
socializing so working um so i feel like there's
gonna be like this tug of war between you know
government um you know their own cryptocurrency
cbdc's and then the crypto community who are
pushing that narrative that we spoke about earlier
i think they all coexist i don't think rid of
bitcoin i think it ends up being the reserve
asset that has a lot of value to a lot of people
some governments will adopt it some will try and
regulate against it i just think it's going to be
there like gold it's always been there people have
tried to ban it from time to time never really
work so i don't have a i don't think they have
an issue with it either the central bank digital
currencies are a whole different thing um what
that is is at the top level yeah it's much easier
for me to send you money right one second thing
great it means that stuff like bitcoin becomes
seamless into this so for taxation capturing and
all of this stuff that makes nation states making
nation states fine it's gonna completely change
how economics works because monetary policy run
by central banks fiscal policy run by governments
that all blends into one because this is the rise
again of behavioural economics and big data sets
because i can incentivize you differently to me
you can have a different rate of interest you can
we can do down to the individual in terms of
stimulus or penalty reward systems but obviously
governments can use it for nefarious means
too so if they catch you driving you know
five miles an hour over the speed limit they'll
just take it straight from your wallet because
oh that's scary that brings me out
yeah um and that and that's the problem
um but it's incredibly powerful in a recession
like this to have gone okay hairdressing salons
right here's that here's you know here's 10 grand
in your account immediately um and we'll monitor
your wallet and if you're running out of cash
we'll redo that for stimulus that would have
really helped yes as opposed to giving it to
a bunch of banks via quantitative easing and
assuming they're going to do the right thing which
they won't because they'll either hoard it or
give it to their best customers so the people who
actually need it can't get it you know this again
matters not whether you like it or not it's
coming it's happening it's freaky programmable
money at central bank level is definitely going
to happen well there you go i was going to ask
you your last thoughts but i think that's it isn't
it programmable money on a central bank level is
going to happen yeah there you go please get the
heads around that well i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure um and thank you so
much for coming on yeah really enjoyed it all
right guys don't forget to tune in next thursday
we will be live at 12 p.m est we'll see you then